as I explained up front we taped this
show just a little bit before it airs a
couple hours before so we don't know we
don't know what Trump's decision is
going to be on his Supreme Court nominee
all we know is that he's announcing it
live during American Ninja Warrior
I believe which delights me boiler alert
yeah it sucks whoever it is defend that
statement you know like any of the or
possibilities here's a problem in all
seriousness it's not fair because Obama
had his pick and they held it up so now
you're a situation where unfortunately
whoever you get because it's Kennedy
because identity is he's a swing vote he
is leaving I was much more
psychologically prepared for Trump to
win than for Kennedy to resign a lot of
liberals said Trump can't win Trump
can't win I'm like you said he would say
look this guy could win I was saying it
the whole time so I was you know I was
only in therapy for several months right
after it I mean I've you know something
you were still in therapy I was you know
I got out early because I was more but I
wasn't prepared for Kennedy to resign
and so that's a huge difference
and when you let somebody like Trump get
you know that appointment you know it's
not gonna be a good appointment it's not
gonna be somebody who's gonna try to
call balls and strikes he wants he wants
to be able to have the court movement
particular way and so whoever he picks
it the past
Trump's litmus test I'm sad yeah okay
all right
you think and obviously such long-term
consequences with a Supreme Court neck
people watching that seeing this now
already know who that who the nominee is
we don't but this person is going to
have yeah a lot huge huge influence
listen don't forget marriage equality
it's a four five vote with Kennedy I
mean you you start walking through stuff
that matters to you a lot of these three
four or five votes with Kennedy I'm not
saying that they're for these things are
going to go away what I am gonna say is
we're gonna have to start doing things
like voting again midterm elections
coming up my fraud with the Democrats
right now is we're in the middle of the
most important midterm election in our
lives look at your Facebook feed
nobody's talking about that we're
talking about tweets we're talking about
Bob Muller we're talking about porn
stars talking about everything in the
world except the fact that if you get
twenty three seats as a Democrat this
November you can start putting a stop to
the crazy if you get twenty two you live
in crazy forever that's basically where
we are
you